Olá eu sou Dr Alan Dutra hoje estamos
dando continuidade à nossa importante
conversa sobre a dengue agora falando da
prevenção e tratamento no nosso primeiro
vídeo falamos dos sintomas e dos sinais
de alerta que podem indicar a forma
grave da dengue se você ainda não viu eu
recomendo fortemente que assista para
ficar por dentro de informações cruciais
o link está na descrição do vídeo mas
hoje vamos avançar pra segunda parte
dessa série Vamos explorar as
possibilidades de prevenção e tratamento
envolvendo vitaminas suplementos ervas e
medidas importantes que podem ser
adotadas para fortalecer nosso corpo
contra essa ameaça entendam meus amigos
que a dengue é descrita como uma doença
Sem tratamento específico no caso
tratamento é apenas sintomático mas há
coisas que podemos fazer para ajudar a
passar melhor pela fase da doença
deixando o seu sistema de defesa o
sistema imune mais forte o que eu vou
explicar no vídeo de hoje não é em si
considerado oficialmente um tratamento
para dengue e não garante que você
estará livre dela mas são medidas que eu
considero importantes e que podem fazer
toda a diferença pessoal hoje vamos além
da conversa habitual sobre evitar água
parada claro todos sabemos que eliminar
os focos de água parada é parte
fundamental na luta contra a dengue Mas
vamos ser sinceros mesmo sendo
vigilantes em nossos lares e locais de
trabalho o risco ainda espreita muitas
vezes em áreas que fogem ao nosso
controle por isso é hora de conhecer
outras armas naturais que temos à
disposição para reforçar nossa defesa
contra o aedes egipte eu quero
compartilhar com vocês um segredo da
natureza que é incorporar plantas
repelentes de mosquito no ambiente de
nossa casa integrar plantas como alecrim
lavanda citronela e melaleuca no
ambiente doméstico pode ser uma
estratégia inteligente para ajudar a
afastar o mosquito da dengue essas
plantas são conhecidas por suas
propriedades repelentes naturais não só
contribuem para um ambiente mais
agradável aromático em casa mas também
atua como uma medida adicional contra o
aeds egípcio que é o transmissor da
dengue pessoal lembre-se apesar dessas
plantas serem auxiliares valiosos elas
não são uma solução única o mosquito da
dengue é astuto ele se esconde em
lugares inimagináveis por isso além das
plantas Recomendo o uso de óleos
essenciais no difusor para espalhar
esses aromas repelentes pelo ambiente o
alecrim a lavanda a citronela e o
hortelã pimenta são ótimos Aliados nessa
batalha contra o mosquito diante do
aumento de casos de dengue especialmente
em áreas suscetíveis à proliferação do
vetor o aeds egipt é imprescindível a
adoção de medidas preventivas entre elas
o uso de repelentes pessoal um dos
repelentes mais eficazes conhecido é
aquele a base de
icaridina esse composto é altamente
eficiente contra o mosquito transmissor
da dengue sendo recomendado por sua
longa duração de ação Além disso é
impossível não mencionar os repelentes
naturais como é o caso da citronela e o
óleo de hortelã pimenta a citronela seja
em forma de óleo essencial ou mesmo
cultivada ao redor da sua casa é famosa
por afugentar os mosquitos com sua
fragrância no mercado há uma vasta gama
de produtos contendo citronela devido à
sua eficácia reconhecida por outro lado
o óleo de hortelã pimenta tem se
destacado em pesquisas por reduzir
notavelmente as picadas dos mosquitos da
dengue mais atenção ao uso de acordo com
as instruções do fabricante já que pode
causar irritação na pele em algumas
pessoas Vale ressaltar também que embora
efetivos esses repelentes naturais podem
necessitar de reaplicações mais
constantes em comparação a icaridina
devido ao tempo de ação mais limitado
além de adotar práticas específicas de
prevenção contra o mosquito transmissor
da dengue como evitar água parada usar
repelentes e cultivar plantas com
propriedades repelentes há um elemento
crucial que eu sempre faço questão de
destacar em meus vídeos a importância de
um estilo de vida saudável
essa abordagem vai além do bem-estar
geral desempenhando um papel Vital na
prevenção de diversas doenças Inclusive
a dengue a verdade é que quanto mais
saudável for o seu estado geral de saúde
maiores serão as suas chances de uma
recuperação completa caso venha a
contrair a doença pessoal um sistema de
defesa imune forte é a nossa principal
defesa contra os mais variados agentes
patogênicos e incluindo aqueles
transmitidos por mosquitos para isso uma
dieta rica em nutrientes focada em
alimentos naturais e com mínimo de
processamento é fundamental para
potencializar a nossa imunidade
alimentos repletos de gorduras saudáveis
como azeite de oliva óleo de coco
abacate carboidratos complexos obtidos
de alimentos como batata doce mandioca
nhame proteínas de alta qualidade vindas
de ovos peixes e carnes além de uma
ampla variedade verduras legumes e
frutas compõe uma alimentação
equilibrada que nutre não apenas nosso
corpo mas também reforço o sistema
imunológico e não podemos esquecer da
importância Vital de um sono de
qualidade e da prática regular de
exercícios físicos agora eu quero falar
sobre um complemento que tem chamado
atenção por suas notáveis propriedades é
o própolis esse produto natural não é
apenas um aliado devido às suas
características antiv virais e também
antioxidantes mas também tem um papel
fascinante em como interagimos com o
ambiente ao nosso redor inclusive no que
diz respeito ao mosquito da dengue
pessoal estudo sugere que o consumo
regular de própolis pode alterar a nossa
exalação através do suor liberando
compostos ativos como flavonas e
vitamina B conhecidos por suas
propriedades repelentes naturais contra
o mosquito transmissor da dengue uma
pesquisa que foi conduzida ao longo de 5
anos na Amazônia demonstrou que o
própolis pode ser um meio eficaz de
prevenção mantendo Esses mosquitos a uma
distância segura de nós além de suas
qualidades preventivas a própolis Verde
em particular se destaca na luta contra
a dengue tanto na prevenção quant
tratamento suas propriedades
antiinflamatórias tornam uma forte
aliada no combate aos sintomas da doença
em momentos de infecção por deng
a contagem de plaquetas é um indicador
fundamental Vital da gravidade da
situação e a próprio Lis Verde tem
mostrado promessa em acelerar a
recuperação das plaquetas durante a
infecção além de ajudar a mitigar outros
sintomas Associados como febre malestar
e dores corporais vai proporcionar sim
um alívio significativo ao paciente e
ainda amigos a própolis Verde também tem
o potencial de reduzir a duração da
doença
isso não apenas proporciona um conforto
mais rápido ao paciente mas também
diminui as chances de complicações
sérias decorrentes da dengue eu quero
enfatizar aqui um ponto crucial no
tratamento da dengue que normalmente se
foca em aliviar os sintomas da doença já
que até o momento não existe um
tratamento antiviral específico
disponível vamos falar mais sobre isso
daqui a pouco a abordagem padrão inclui
garantir que o paciente Descanse o
suficiente manté uma uma hidratação
adequada e utilize medicamentos para
combater a febre e as dores pelo corpo
aqui eu tenho um alerta importante que
eu já mencionei em vários vídeos mas que
vale a pena reiterar o
paracetamol é frequentemente recomendado
pro tratamento sintomático da dengue
Porque tem uma eficácia como antitérmico
e analgésico contudo é preciso ter uma
atenção especial com esse medicamento
especialmente considerando os riscos de
sobrecarga hepática de sobrecarga ao
fígado a dengue pode afetar esse órgão
tornando crucial a escolha de
medicamentos que não exerçam pressão
adicional sobre esse órgão Vital Nesse
contexto a dipirona surge como
alternativa preferencial dado a sua
segurança em relação a função hepática e
o menor risco de exacer de problemas
hepáticos em pacientes com dengue Além
disso é fundamental evitar o uso do as
ou ácido acetilsalicílico devido a seu
potencial para para aumentar o risco de
sangramentos esse cuidado é
especialmente importante em uma doença
como a dengue que pode comprometer a
coagulação do sangue e aumentar a
suscetibilidade a complicações
hemorrágicas no caminho da prevenção e
tratamento da dengue é vital reforçar a
ideia de que qualquer plano de
tratamento seja ele focado em medicação
para aliviar sintomas ou na
suplementação devee ser cuidadosamente
acompanhado por um profissional de saúde
pessoal não faça nada sozinho entre
suplementos que podem ser considerados
tanto para prevenção quanto para
tratamento da dengue destaca--se a
quercetina esse flavonoide natural que é
encontrado em alimentos como frutas
vermelhas maçãs cebolas pimentões e
brócolis possui propriedades antivirais
antiinflamatórias e antioxidantes
acetina é particularmente interessante
por sua capacidade inibir a ligação do
vírus da dengue à células hospedeiras e
a replicação viral intracelular a sua
suplementação pode ser uma estratégia
eficaz para fortalecer a resposta do
organismo à infecção já a vitamina D de
dado três também é fundamental atuando
mais como um hormônio do que uma
vitamina porque regula o sistema
imunológico e fortalece as defesas
naturais do corpo contra o vírus da
dengue manter níveis adequados essa
vitamina é bem importante para a
imunidade robusta e saudável agora uma
vitamina que é de extrema importância é
a B12 especialmente and o seu papel na
formação de células sanguíneas incluindo
as plaquetas plaquetas baixas ou como
nós chamamos na medicina trombocitopenia
são uma preocupação significativa na
dengue porque aumenta o risco de
sangramento em casos graves pode levar a
complicações que são potencialmente
fatais pesquisas sugerem uma relação
direta entre níveis adequados de
vitamina B12 e a contagem de plaquetas
em pacientes com dengue onde a
deficiência dessa vitamina pode resultar
em uma recuperação mais lenta e
complicações mais graves da doença Eu
recomendo manter um nível mínimo de 600
pic GR por ml de vitamina B12 no sangue
para assegurar um estado saudável na
produção de plaquetas a suplementação de
zinco pode ser eficaz no tratamento da
dengue segundo diversos estudos e aí Por
falar em estudos eu vou estar deixando
todos eles na descrição do vídeo os
links estão na descrição esse mineral é
essencial pro sistema imune ajudando na
modulação da resposta imunológica e
combatendo a replicação do vírus da
dengue a suplementação de zinco pode ser
um complemento valioso para fortalecer a
imunidade e auxiliar no tratamento da
doença Lembra quando eu falei do papel
do fígado na doença voltando a esse
assunto temos a nsí unac que se destaca
por seu papel antioxidante especialmente
eficaz na proteção do F fígado contra
danos causados por toxinas e infecções
como a dengue o nac ajuda a repor os
níveis de glutationa um dos
antioxidantes mais importantes do corpo
que é crucial pra desintoxicação
hepática dado que o fígado é um dos
órgãos Alvo na infecção pela dengue
resultando frequentemente em
comprometimento hepático o uso de nac
etil cisteína pode oferecer proteção
adicional contra
hepatotoxicidade e ajudar na recuperação
de lesões hepáticas leves a grav
Associados a dengue em caso de dengue o
comprometimento do fígado pode variar de
alterações leves nas enzimas hepáticas a
quadros mais sérios como hepatite A ação
protetora do nac sobre o fígado pode ser
particularmente benéfica ajudando a
mitigar a diminuir o impacto do vírus e
dar suporte ao processo de recuperação
do fígado e quanto a medicamentos bem
antes de eu mencionar algum vamos
conversar sobre algo bastante comum na
medicina mas que talvez muitos de vocês
não conheçam é uso off Label de
medicamentos essa prática refere-se a
quando o medicamento é utilizado por uma
condição não especificada em sua mla
oficial especialmente em situações onde
as opções de tratamento são escassas ou
em casos de doenças graves emergências
de saúde pública um exemplo interessante
dessa aplicação é o montelucaste é um
medicamento conhecido por seu uso num
tratamento de condições alérgicas como
as e rinite então estudos iniciais
mostraram que ele pode ter um papel no
tratamento da dengue isso acontece
porque o Montel Lu cast atua
estabilizando os mastócitos que são
células de defesa que quando ativadas
liberam mediadores inflamatórios no caso
da dengue o vírus pode ativar esses
mastócitos causando liberação de
mediadores que levam a dano a órgãos em
situações graves choque e morte a
habilidade do Montel cast em estabilizar
mastos e potencialmente diminuir a
resposta inflamatória sugere que ele
pode ajudar a proteger contra o avanço
da dengue para formas mais graves tem um
estudo que indicou que o uso de Montel
cast pode diminuir em 71 o risco de
evolução para dengue grave comparado com
terapias convencionais isso é
especialmente significativo considerando
a ausência de tratamentos específicos
para a dengue e a busca contínua por
novas estratégias para gerenciar e
reduzir a severidade dessa doença agora
vamos tocar em um ponto tanto
problemático e sem dúvida interessante
existe ainda Uma dupla bem famosa aqui
no Brasil vocês já ouviram falar delas
com certeza são aquelas cantora sabem é
a Anita e a Ivete Anita Ivete uma dupla
polêmica mas que já mostrou potenciais
interessantes contra dengue e outro
vírus mais polêmico Ainda bem
infelizmente não posso ser mais mais
específico do que isso nessa plataforma
mas para bons entendedores minhas
palavras bastam não é então tem vários
estudos em vitro mostrando atividade
antiviral contra a dengue dessa dupla de
cantoras também temos colegas muito
sérios e respeitados comentando sobre
isso infelizmente ainda carecemos de
estudos de larga escala do efeito da
dupla em seres humanos Será que o uso se
justificaria em caso de emergência
pública anos atrás quando era para
tratar piolho e verminose não existia
polêmica quanto a segurança mas eu deixo
vocês pensarem refletirem sobre isso são
essas três medicações com uso off Label
que são interessantes no tratamento da
deng pessoal é fundamental compreender
que o uso off Label de medicamentos como
no caso do tratamento da dengue deve ser
baseado em uma avaliação cuidadosa por
parte do médico esses tratamentos
sugeridos nesse vídeo não são uma cura
para doença Mas eles podem ser bem úteis
com respaldo científico e prática médica
extensa em tratamento ativo de muitos
colegas com seus pacientes é essencial
que qualquer uso seja feito sobre a
supervisão de um médico
qualificado familiarizados com os
protocolos e doses adequadas para cada
situação evitando sempre a automedicação
pessoal Muito obrigado pela sua atenção
um grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
e você é fera Y